the first overall pick in the 2022 draft first
ever Slovak taken number one Carolina trying
to mount some offense terrain he'll get it
to AO AO get it right down the middle of
the score Burns staying red hot and the canes
jump out to the quick lead it's one- nothing
Carolina Burns made a fabulous pass on the back
hand defensively with a ton of pressure Terra
gets to it doesn't connect with AO just on S I'm
sure Montreal is looking at that and then he wires
it you got a stick in the lane from spetch nikov
to this thing stands AO is going to get another
point he just gets it to the net quickly and FES
nikov gets it I love what burns did in his own
end with pressure and then terab as the gains
put the pressure on here abon's able to skate
this one out then he'll have it lifted neatly
good work now by skull and he'll rip a shot
that is handled by Primo Kane's keeping in good
steal by fetch nikov he'll lay this one out for
slaven slaven he'll drop it back AO back to slaven
Around the Net try for the onetime but failing to
pull the trigger now back for bur out front they
score yes for fost on the porch and knocks it
home two guys we talked about in the open AO
and burns have been all over this thing slav
it uses the back of the net F missfires AO wins
a battle and then one betters himself instead of
deflecting it at the net an intended pass to
yesper fos and the breakdown in the interior
then it occurred for the Montreal Canadians
Burns gets his second point of the night AO
gets his second point of now he'd like to get on
the score sheet tonight Jaden strubel played his
college hockey at Northeastern deliver
this puck in the kan's end and chasing
after it Montreal gets to it first back for
strel deflected out in front rebound chance
to score Mitchell Stevens to the rebound and he
deposits it high under the crossbar the initial
shot peshy blocked and he was stung lost his
footing goes back to the front of the net
looks like he wins the box out Canadians
get the puck to the net quickly it hits
pesi Ron can't locate where that puck is going
bunting's trying to go stick on Puck and a nice
job on the backand of it helped that the puck
was on edge with regards to Elevation see that
development in jaur he game I'm getting back to
the game I had an afternoon with mle crew but
it didn't involve the stage I believe this is
zoff will carry this puck in Carolina the shot
deflicted up FR they score Jack Drury getting
to the front of the net yes for fost throws it
out front jewry bangs it home in Carolina
gets their two goal lead back it's 3-1 boy
we saw last night twice in the second period
when Nashville scored goals and now tonight
big response even strength goals this goes
legally off of Jack bre's skate I believe
maybe his knee then down to escate really good
job from orlock driving the middle pushing the
Montreal defense back Marty s Lou I'm sure is
considering challenging this but I don't that
puck is already in the crease and once the that
exact thing Tri I've learned to you know never
make I mean that's a penalty technically speaking
stick on the hands it's got to be a contributing
factor to this review after video review it's
determined that there is golender interference
on the play no goal his best save of the period
And so timely could change the complexion of the
intermission if you finish Le 10 seconds off roll
the side of the net stretch play they'll score
mat went around the net the defenseman snuck
it past R and Jacob slaven and we're tied at
two obviously Auntie bit on the fact that a shot
was going to come and mat a defenseman jumping in
has found a home in Montreal that looks like it's
just on side it's close and I I would say in this
case that Auntie over burns with another pinch to
keep it in he'll get it to F just take a hit to
make a play there from gly Puck into the corner n
will do the same gie they'll send it up in front
the score yes for fost his second of the game and
the kinges jump out to a quick lead in the second
period but confidence can do for your hands after
you get the first goal boss buries this after
a clinical below the goal line for check from n
and Jack grur I mean absolute compete and support
Curry gets in finishes gets the support from n
they both delivered the goods big time with a
capital b and a capital T below the goal line
former hurricane Max Patch ready to the Vegas
gold Knights now this pucks chipped out of the
pame zone and Jarvis shot out of a cannon will
get to it puts a shot right on rebounds out there
Ron is on his post now toorak to it now set up for
R makes the save on Gallagher he just bailed out
C YY minute 15 left here in the second period Aria
trying to work his way around Chatfield mil turn
that'll be deflected out in front Ron doesn't see
it makes a rebound still there crashing the net
is the B and somehow R and keeps it out that would
be acceptable you already have two Martin gets a
shot be deflected away good looking stall over top
exchanging with Jarvis back up to Shay shot he f
on it here comes Anderson Anderson in on R holding
he squeaks it and he'll get through well turnabout
for Montreal they've given up a goal in the first
90 seconds 95 of the first and second now they
scored 25 seconds here into the third miss the
Brady Shay Puck was flat he just missed fired may
he caught it too much on the heel and I thought
Josh Anderson who has been after not scoring at
eons and I might I mean eons has been scoring
with regularity recently that was the speed up the
ice as peshi was chasing him down that he had as a
Columbus Bluejack and he opens up Ron Ron gets
a lot of it but he isn't able to get enough of
it I wonder if now you have a different well the
canes win the draw peshi he gets it across the no
score Andre speet nikov doesn't need a power
play he's got a power shot and the canes in the
lead and he does it with a purpose that prevents
Baron from getting over and making the play you
got to win the draw cleanly a did he's
been winning a ton of draws especially
on the power play and Primo was halfway
out of his net had to Retreat back in now
yes for fost with it getting it to martinook
now stall he'll chip one and martinook will
settle it down back up in front for stall
Primo with the save oh kayen Primo's best
save of the night there fabulous stop late in
the hockey game with the lead the Martino Fox
stall line reunite now AO has it knocked
away mat Primo heads to the bench for the
extra attacker it's on the stick of sikov
takes a for the hatrick big oh here come the
hats Carolina's on the power play this
would have if it went for icing given
Montreal with a decent amount
of time left when power plays
in go tending carried it last night were
they ever a line Brewery line stall line